I don't see how undocumented immigrants
who are not in the system they're not on
the books coming in here hurts people
who are legally coming here because if
they're undocumented they're not being
put into a queue it's not like over full
now described exactly what it is there's
a limited capacity as to how many people
can have in a country especially when
you have people who takes us to number
two right are a net burden on the
American taxpayer it costs a lot of
money to have a legal immigration system
right it costs a lot of money to be able
to monitor to be able to approve visas
to get people to this country legally
every country since the beginning of
time has had borders and has had a
monitoring system to make sure that
people who are in the confines of their
country are there legally are you sure
I'm fairly sure there's some uh ones in
Europe and they have very open borders
but the United States isn't one of those
Nations we are a nation with a system of
laws we do have a system for legal
immigration and you are to abide by that
current system